welcome welcome we are going to be
starting promptly at 3 o'clock but we're
going to start letting our participants
come in so thank you for joining us
today hello hello
hello thank you all for joining us us we
still have some participants coming in
so we're going to start
promptly at the top of the
hour so as you are coming in um if you
have any questions at any time during
our session you can drop them in a Q&A
we are being joined by some of our Khan
Academy team members who will be
answering questions in the Q&A so please
feel free at any time to um drop any
questions that you may have in our Q&A
section have about one more
minute
all right it is the top of the hour and
so we are going to um get started we
want to Welcome All of You here uh today
to join us for our SE our session um our
the title of our session is kigo KH
Academy's AI tool for the classroom the
teacher and student Edition my name is
Dian klingman I am a professional
learning specialist here with uh here at
Khan
Academy and I am also joined
by hello hello everyone my name is
Michelle marbar and I too am on the
professional learning team at Con
Academy and I hope everybody is having a
wonderful
Wednesday all right so we're going to
get
started so before we dive into our
content for today we want to hear from
you the audience so using AI to support
student learning is a New Concept and so
it's a um it's going to be plenty of
time for everyone to learn about all the
various tools that are available to you
as an educator so before we get started
we we just want to know from you um how
familiar are you with AI and student
learning so there's going to be a poll
that's about to pop up and we just want
to know are you a very familiar you
regularly use it in your classrooms you
might be somewhat familiar you've used
it a few times you might be slightly
familiar you know you've heard about it
tried it once or twice or you're just
not familiar at all and you're just here
to kind of learn a little bit more about
it so okay we're seeing that there's
some people somewhat familiar
okay we have some slightly
familiar because we I mean we're all
learning at this point so this is new so
thank you for you know sharing kind of
where you are at this
point all right and so for those of you
that may not you know be as familiar we
hope by the end of this you know this
session you have a lot of your questions
answered um that you may have at this
time all right so most of you probably
already
know KH Academy as a free resource that
includes videos articles and exercises
and we know that that's true we are
about giving a free education to anyone
anywhere but however we also now have a
paid District partnership um that's
available for those districts that are
looking to to get a little bit more
support and so in this paid District
partnership we have uh this this
partnership grants both teachers and
students access to conmigo which is our
chatbot and kigo provides that in the
moment personalized support for students
when they encounter encounter learning
difficulties also a part of this uh paid
District partnership come some
wraparound services that support both
teachers and administrators and we offer
robust professional de professional
development and in that professional
development we incorporate practical
strategies for incorporating AI into the
classrooms and so this type of
wraparound support it ex stands through
the through the whole duration of our
partnership
together so you also may be wondering
what is the difference between K Migo
and chat
GPT so by now in the news I'm pretty
sure you've heard of chat GPT which is
this large language artificial
intelligent it's a large language
artificial intelligence model but unlike
chat GPT kigo was specifically designed
with Educators and students in mind so
some of the things that kigo doeses is
kigo prioritizes safety and data
management kigo adheres to the to
privacy and data protection guidelines
like furpa and Copa kigo is also a
Socratic tutor that's going to guide
students uh guide students when they are
stuck on a specific problem and it's not
just going to give them the the direct
answer conmigo is also going to provide
a comprehensive learning experience for
for students and then as a teacher or
educ as an educator kigo will also
partner with you and support you with
co-creating some high qual quality
lesson plans and assist you with the
progress monitoring
process so as you begin to implement
kigo into your learning environment this
is a new tool so with any anything that
is new is going to be important that you
carefully introduce kigo to your
students you want your students to know
and understand the clear expectations
around using kigo we know that as
Educators when we set those clear
expectations students are more than more
than likely to meet them because they
understand the why behind why this tool
why this tool is being used in their
classroom
so as you begin to carefully introduce
this to your students you want your
students to know that their brain is
their first
supercomputer our um our human brain is
is designed to create to to have to to
think creatively right and so AI cannot
do that we want our students to still be
those creative thinkers when students
are stuck on a specific uh Concept in
our classes we already give them some
tools to do what are some things that
you can do when you get stuck you can
ask a friend you can refer back to your
notes you can even use manipulatives or
you probably have anchor charts up in
your classrooms um for students to
reference if they you know if they get
stuck they can even ask you as the
teacher but now you are bringing kigo
into your classrooms to now be that
additional tool for students to have
when they are stuck in their learning AI
is not meant to uh to replace creative
thinking and so because of that it's
still going to be important that as
Educators we continue to establish that
um that very high culture of creative
thinking in our in our
classrooms you also want your students
to know and understand that kigo is
going to be there to help them grow they
should understand that this is a tool
that's going to help them grow and gain
confidence in their studies kigo can
also interact with students in in
another in other languages other than
English so if you have students that are
currently in your classroom and English
is not their first language kigo can
interact with them in their home
language and so by removing that barrier
this is going to give all students in
your classrooms the opportunity to
interact and and interact and contribute
to um to the classroom in a very
meaningful
way
and earlier you heard me mention that we
have our district uh our district
partnership that includes the robust
professional development well as part of
our professional development we are we
do train on what it means to be AI
literate and so as you are introducing
AI uh literacy to your students it's
going to be very important that your
students understand one what is AI right
what what can it do and how should it be
used and all of this is available
through our
partnership as um if you decide to
become one of our partners we definitely
talk about this in our professional
learning sessions and so with that I am
now going to turn it over to
Michelle thank you so much Diana this is
actually my favorite part because I love
sharing all of the amazing features that
kigo has to support and enhance learning
for your students so let's just dig
right in there so first let's see how
conmigo can be used with in um in the
course I'm going to go ahead into a I'm
going to pull up a
course and when I pull that course up
we're going to be able to see how con
students can use conmigo with that
course um when students open up Con
Academy and they select a video or an
article like is on the screen um
something that they're working on they
have the ability to include kigo into
their Learning Journey by clicking on
the low in the lower left right hand
corner of the
screen and mine is currently in teacher
mode which when I select that it's going
to give me a list of prompts such as do
I want to write a lesson plan or create
warm-up activities for my students but
for today's purposes I'm going to change
it to student mode turn that teacher
mode off because I have my student had
on and then it provides me another set
of pre-populated prompts um that are
related to the content that's on the
screen which are specifically designed
for students to make that learning more
engaging for them so students can also
ask kigo questions but I'm going to
select a I'm going to ask kigo a
question that most of my students asked
me anytime I introduced A New Concept to
them in class why should should I learn
about this so I'm going to select that
and let's see what kigo
says great question knowing how to
evaluate expressions with two variables
is like a secret decoder ring it helps
you solve real world problems for
example if you're baking cookies and the
recipe says two cups of flour for every
one cup of sugar that's an expression
with two variables if you know how many
cookies you you want to make you can
figure out how much do you want to try a
problem from the article now yeah let's
do that yes
please
see all right awesome let's start with
the first practice problem from the
article can you evaluate the expression
6 a + 4 B no I
cannot and as a student I'm just just
interacting with conmigo and conmigo is
going to help support me with answering
the questions and um what what's on the
screen now kigo can also be used
alongside the exercises um in in KH
Academy so I'm going to go ahead and
select one of the
exercises and just like before conmigo
provides me pre-populated prompts
related to the content um that I'm
working on and let's see again why
should I care about this I could ask
that or try a similar example or help me
solve the problem or I can even ask um
my own questions so first I'll do why
should I care about this because I think
that's always interesting well what are
your goals in life all right
kigo I want to be a
singer cool as a singer you might need
to split profits from a song with others
very true this math can help you figure
out how much each person gets does that
make sense
absolutely so now I'm going to go into
now I know why I need to learn it
because I I I want to split my Royal I
don't want to split all my royalties so
I'm going to go into the actual activity
this is what the student see and I'm
just going to ask it what's the answer
because I don't feel like figuring this
out let's see I can't give you the
answer but I can help you find it let's
start by plugging in the values for G
and H into the equation can you do
that
no let's see what kigo helps me
do no worries we can do this together
thank you let's replace the G with 10
and H what do you get and so with with
this cono is not going to give students
the answer at all it's going to be a
thought partner with them and helps them
work through um work through the
exercises now in addition to being um
students being able to access kigo when
they're working actually in a course
with our pay District partnership
students have um access to our cono
dashboard that's designed to support
students in the subjects in Con Academy
as well as other subjects so I'm going
to access that dashboard by selecting
right here where it has AI
activities and I'm going to come down
here and one of the first things I want
to do is how about let's practice my
knowledge this section allows students
to practice and build knowledge in any
subject they select um this feature
meets students where they are and it
helps support them as they build
confidence in the content that they're
working on so first kigo wants to know
what age level am am I um I always love
middle school so I'm going to select
Middle
School great now could you please
specify the subject you'd like to be
quizzed on um it can do Math Science
History English um how about Let's Do
Science and I'm going to ask kigo a
question question that I was that I'm
working on in class My teacher asked me
for homework so can you help me with
understanding cell parts and functions
science is always
fun absolutely we're going to have a
blast exploring the world of cells let's
dive into the first question question
one in a Cell where are the genetic
materials
stored okay I have no idea am am I
smarter than a seventh grader let's
see no worries at all let's think about
this together the genetic material of a
cell is like an instruction man manual
it's stored in a place and so kigo is
going to help me through the process of
learning all about cells now I'm going
to refresh it again and this time I'm
going to select a subject that's not
necessarily in KH Academy how about I'm
a high school student and I'm working in
a pottery class
say
Pottery fantastic Pottery it is get
ready for a whirlwind tour of the world
of Ceramics here comes your first
question what is the process of heating
the pottery to a high temperature to
make it hard and adorable
called got
me
I have no
idea kigo is so smart and I love the way
kigo it helps build a growth mindset for
students and it lets them know it's okay
that they don't know it right now but it
will work work with them and through the
process so it's going to it's all of
these teachable moments and the students
are learning from this entire process
now let's do something else how about
let's go to our debate I love debating
um and it could be because my husband
says that I love to argue not sure but
the debate feature students are able to
first they want to select their school a
appropriate school age and when they do
that they're going to get a list of
prompts and notice the prompts are age
appropriate so Elementary School prompts
are Should students wear school uniforms
or is homework necessary or should it be
banned if I come over to the Middle
School list of
topics they're a little bit more in
depth um schools should schools start
later in the morning should schools
offer art and music classes and I'm
going to come over to the high
school version a little bit more um
higher level so it definitely works with
um age appropriateness of the Stu for
students so I am going to how about
because we're working on AI right now
how about should schools ban students
use of AI to write papers I'm a former
Ela teacher so this is definitely um one
that's near and dear to my heart so I'm
going to select
that all right so great choice now which
side are you on do you think schools
should ban students from using AI to
write papers or do you think they
shouldn't kigo wants to know my side of
the argument so I'm going to say um
no I think they should I don't think
so so all right you're saying schools
shouldn't ban AI for writing papers I'm
all ears and eyes in my case that's
funny kigo definitely has a sense of
humor um so let think of my first
argument how I'm going to
say
because you don't give me the
answer you guide me in the right
direction ah clever point Thank you kigo
you're saying AI can be a guide not a
cheat sheet absolutely but here's a
Twist what if students start relying too
much on AI and start thinking for
themselves it's like using a map so it's
using it's like using a map so much you
forget to explore your turn buddy so
even though kigo is a form of AI it's
still kind of playing the opposite side
and so I need to think about what my
next argument is going to be and we're
just going to go back and forth so I'm
going to give another one how
about because I have to to write an
entire essay on this I'm writing an
argumentative essay for my
class so I believe that AI should be
allowed because it helps me stay focused
on what I'm writing aha you're saying AI
is like a trusty sidekick helping you
stay on track and sparking ideas but
remember too much of a good thing and so
kigo is going to go back and forth and
back and forth and I'm able to debate to
help me create look at the other side of
the spectrum as well so I love that
debate feature it's one of my favorites
now another amazing thing that kigo can
do is give students instant feedback in
our courses um students get immediate
feedback anytime they answer a question
it will provide that immediate feedback
that we know is so important for for
learning however conmigo can also give
immediate feedback as well so this is
the start of my essay so I'm just going
to ask
kigo can you give me feedback can you
give
me and I'm going to spell feedback wrong
so you can see that kigo does not worry
about
spelling which is great thing for me
sure thing partner you've made some
solid points about how AI can help with
Focus organization and idea generation
for improvement let's try to give
specific examples or tell a story to
make yourart argument more convincing
like remember that time AI helped me
structure my essay on dinosaurs so kigo
is not telling me how to do it it's not
writing it for me it's it's my thought
partner and it's kind of like my trusty
sidekick that's going to help me come up
with ideas and thoughts to make the most
amazing essay that I possibly can so I
love this feature on pigo
now another thing that conmigo can do it
can support students in their home
language conmigo is designed with
multilingual capabilities that support
English Spanish as well as Portuguese
these features um these features are
incredible resources for our El students
because it enables them to ask questions
and learn in their home language so I'm
going to select another option how about
let's what should I do what should I
do how about let's chat with a literary
character now although con when a
student selects one of the features the
initial prompts and speech bubbles from
conmigo will not be translated however
if a student writes the kigo in their
language kigo is going to respond to
them in that selected language so I'm
going to
type something to
kigo and let's
see all right it responds in Spanish so
another way teacher um students can
change the language foran Migo is at the
top of the page there are going to be
these three buttons up here students can
select it and select their
preferences and one of the preferences
that they can select is the language so
if they English is the automatic default
language but um students can change it
to Portuguese and they can change it to
Spanish as
well so I love I love that feature
another thing that cono can do on the
teacher side is that let's say a teacher
wants to write a letter home to a parent
but the parent um speaks Portuguese K
Miko can ask or the teacher can ask
kigo to translate that letter to the
parents in um Portuguese or in Spanish
so it's super helpful that way as
well all right another feature that I
want to share is and I think this one
and maybe it's because I'm the mom of
older children I absolutely love this
next feature because cono offers several
tools that focus on postsecondary
activities which are designed to um
assist students in their trans
transition to higher education as well
as care career planning so I could ask
kigo to coach my academic and career
growth I can honestly I could use that
now um why not um or again students can
ask kigo let's navigate College
admission and financial aid so I'm going
to select that so great here um looking
looking at the prompts it says how do I
apply for college what are different
types of secondary education available
or what factors should I consider when
picking a college these are all great
questions how about something that I
know that most college students or um
high school students preparing to go to
college like to ask are how can I pay
for
college I know that's something on the
minds of students as well as
parents paying for college can seem
daunting absolutely but there are a few
key resources that can help
scholarships um grants work study
programs loans personal savings um Does
this answer your question um or can we
move on you know what it does not answer
my question because I don't know what a
grant is so I'm going to say what is a
grant I have no idea I have cousin named
Grant but that's the best I can do a
grant is a type of financial aid that
you don't have to pay back o winner I
love that um grants are often um need
based meaning they're given out based on
a family's financial situation and it
goes through all of the different
features oo it brings up about the fast
um the fs F
FSA I don't know what that is so I'm
going to ask
kigo what is this spasa what is this
called f
FSA because remember I'm in 10th Grade
or 11th grade so I have no idea what
these things
are it stands for free application for
federal student aid oh okay great great
great thank you thank you kigo that is
very very helpful so again students can
use this to help with that postsecondary
exploration um you know they have
guidance counselors but realistically
how often are students able to visit a
guidance counselor they can work be at
home they can do this they can sit with
a parent they can go on kigo and ask
conmigo all types of questions which
will help educate them as well as
parents now I know I've been talking a
lot about all of the Great features that
kigo has for students but I don't want
us to forget about all of the amazing
resources that are available for
teachers as well with our paid District
partnership students um will be
automatically rostered so teachers have
access to this is one of my favorite
things for teachers it's called the
class snapshot so I'm going to go ahead
and collect select that so the class
snapshot gives teachers a quick overview
of how students are performing in class
on Con Academy to help ensure that
students are using the program with
Fidelity and that they're getting the
support that they need um that's
necessary for them to be successful so
once I select that class snapshot
feature cono is going to ask me which
class I could have multiple classes so
I'm going to select my algebra
class all right once I select that kigo
is going to give give me lots of great
information about how my students are
performing and it just gives me a high
level overview of their performance for
the last seven days and it's going to
highlight areas such as recent activity
what have my students been doing this
week uh are they on track to hit their
course Mastery goals um have they
completed any assignments what
assignments are they working on and what
skills are they working on how's their
skill development going it's also going
to provide me these links that give me
direct access to the um reports that are
in my class that I'm getting from from
KH Academy so I can always select that
and it'll take me directly to these
specific reports now at the bottom it's
going to give me um prompts which will
help me learn about what my students are
doing so I can find out what student
should I celebrate with the work that
they've done last week um who needs a
check in it lets me know what students
are struggling give me a list of
students who are 25% or more towards
their Mastery goal I need to know who's
progressing who's not and then this one
I think is my favorite because we all
know the importance of small group
instruction or skill-based group
instruction but we don't necessarily
have the time to create those groups
with kigo does it instantly for me so I
can select group my group my class by
their
recommendations when I select that
conmigo again remember it's my students
are automatically rostered so conmigo
has access to my students and it's going
to group them for me based on a course
that I'm working on so I can use all of
these different features with conmigo I
can ask kigo about a specific student so
I have my students over here I can ask
cono
go can you create a
report for
Amanda let's
see absolutely let's take a look here's
Amanda's
progress and again it's going to show me
how Amanda's done the last seven
weeks and if let's say I had to go to a
parent teacher conference I can just
bring this with me but wait you know
what Amanda's mom speaks Spanish can you
translate
this to
Spanish Let's
see and it'll translate it for Spanish
for me so although Amanda's mom doesn't
speak English I can keep Amanda's mom
informed of her progress on how she's
doing in my course so lots of of great
features it it's just it's super super
cool so incor when teachers incorporate
kigo into the classroom it's it's like a
teaching assistant it's the teaching
assistant I've always wanted and it's an
absolute game changer for teachers as
well as students so I am going to pass
this back to Deana thank you so much for
your time and letting me share all of
these incredible features
today well thank you thank you Michelle
and so with everything that we've talked
about you're probably trying to think
about you know how are how is teaching
and learning going to adapt as AI
becomes prevalent well one of the things
we do want to um to highlight with you
that it's going to be very important
that you establish guidelines for
plagiarism and clearly communicate that
to students they should students should
understand that original work is going
to be important and if they do use AI
they need to site the sources and they
should also understand that they should
only use AI if the assignment um allows
it or it's required to use it and as
part of our um paid District partnership
we you can receive uh support around
planning and sharing what those
guidelines would be so that you can
share them to all of your
stakeholders
so with AI being new and as well as with
kigo it is so much to learn and so on
behalf of KH Khan Academy we want to
share a couple of resources with you so
on our Khan Academy website you are
going to find um con for educators which
is a teacher support course that
includes a unit on um kigo and it has
some videos on on there as well and then
we also have a short but powerful AI
education course located in our course
library that we encourage you to um
check out as well and we are going to
share uh the the links to both of those
in a follow-up um email um after this
presentation so from from moving
barriers to supporting um student
learning imagine also Imagine your
students getting that in the moment
support and feedback especially during
those times when you are busy with your
other teacher task well kigo provides
that as Michelle just uh uh highlighted
if you want to be able to track your
students progress and have data at your
fingertips to share with your students
and your parents and if you are a
classroom teacher even with your
administrators when you become a paid
District partner kigo and KH Academy has
you covered in that area as well so the
only thing left to do is just try it out
um the link there's a link that you see
on the screen but don't try to write it
down because it's going to be emailed to
you after this presentation so please be
on the lookout for a follow-up email
that's going to have links to uh to some
resources as well as the recording of
this uh presentation so with that we
thank you so so much for joining us
today and we hope you have a great rest
of your day as well as the great rest of
your week so take care and feel free to
reach out if you have any
questions thank you so much have a great
day everybody thank you thank you so
much happy
learning have fun with
kigo
all right take care
everyone have a wonderful
Wednesday happy hump
day see you
later